[Music]
[Applause]
uh all right big introduction uh once
again Paulie's learned to play a new
instrument here our drum roll
yeah yeah former Notre Dame
college football
kickoff and uh he's one of the hosts
with two pros and a cup of joe let's
bring in Brady Quinn
[Applause]
we thought we were going short sleeve
today to show us the guns and to send a
message to Will Ferrell because as you
have brought to our attention before
when you played for Notre Dame
Will Ferrell would be uh yelling at you
okay I think this is what we need to do
to get the bottom of this right here's
what I'm thinking so at the Coliseum at
the Coliseum of course you weren't
coming to South Bend well I've been have
you been I've been a couple times
not on the field okay okay well yeah in
this case you were definitely on the
field all right at least I thought it
was you yeah if you could humor me all
right and just say
hey number ten your pants are too high
if you just say that that's probably
that's something I would have said that
sounds like you yeah yeah hey number ten
your pants are too high
I know it's been a long time most
definitely wait wait that's your trash
talking yeah I don't go for like like
obvi like your mama I don't do it no
like that can I be honest though
looked at my backup and I was like is
that real phone I was like my pants too
high and I was like I mean I know I have
long legs but I mean geez and then I I
don't know I was probably all I was
thinking about for the next five minutes
I mean it was definitely a great tactic
hey number ten you run awkwardly there
it is that's the style okay wow
that's penetrating yeah I mean that
hurts but you heard it I heard it I
think the next week I probably was
sagging a little bit my pants or I did
something to alter my uniform all
because of Will Ferrell I know I used to
scream at the mascot whoever the Stu the
the Leprechaun the leprechaun yeah yeah
I would say leprechaun
leprechaun a leprechaun
and I'd say FU
okay uh did USC recruit you uh no so USC
Miami
um
Florida State were probably the three
schools that did not recruit me pretty
much everyone else okay and if USC had
recruited you oh I was
such a baby such a mama's boy and all
that I took a trip to Colorado
and that was back when Gary Barnett was
there so they're starting to kind of get
things going
and and he gives me a book the book is
about his success that he had at
Northwestern
so I started reading back it's a long
flying back from from Denver to Ohio and
I get like 40 pages in and it was
actually a letter of hate mail someone
bought the book sent it to him and was
saying all the stuff how he was a fraud
he was this and that and I was like man
this is this is like must be an omen and
I had family at that point in time I I
still have family in Colorado so it
wouldn't have been that big of an
adjustment uh but my parents come
couldn't come watch me play it wasn't as
naturally televised as it is today why
didn't you stay why didn't you go to
Ohio State since you were from Ohio
um you know it was tough growing up
Columbus honestly having it be like
right there in your backyard but
I felt like Notre Dame was just a better
fit for me I love Ty Willingham that was
who I went to go play for he ran a
version of the West Coast offense from
his time with Denny green with the
Minnesota Vikings
um that appealed to me and I think the
one thing that kept laying in the back
of my head because I was also at that
age I was a big Tom Brady fan so so
Michigan was in the mix
and I always thought to myself man look
at the lineage of quarterbacks that went
to the NFL from Notre Dame and Michigan
and at that point if you had pointed
someone at Ohio State you would have
said
Arch Lister yeah I mean he was he was
probably the best then but it had been a
while and I wanted to go to a place
where I feel like it prepared me for
everything you know academically
athletically and that way if I had a
shot to go pro that was the best place
to do it it was just the best fit for me
should Reggie Bush get his Heisman
Trophy back
oh man what a loaded question so uh I'll
say this Reggie was the best college
football player that I've ever seen in
at least in my time uh there was never a
time when you thought he wasn't going to
score a touchdown
and what gets complicated about it is is
kind of what you brought up
where we're in a world now where
especially young people they don't care
you know they don't care if he accepted
something back then because they look at
nil and they say well you know it's
allowed now
the problem is how you go about doing it
now is different than what was happening
back then that being said I mean
I think the way we've penalized not only
Reggie but even USC afterwards is what
always strikes me is like thank you
something happens thank you and then you
penalize the people after him like he he
doesn't face any consequences so look I
I've always uh championed for him to be
able to get it back as hard as that is
for me to admit a Southern Cal guy and
all that uh he was the greatest college
football player I've seen so rightfully
so and Marvel I think you just brought
it up right like you did not see that
like trust me I witnessed everything
that happened when we were playing
against him in that Heyday so you can't
unsee it but at the same time
there's still a line that was crossed
you know and it's interesting this whole
defamation lawsuit I would make the case
like him not having his Heisman has
actually given him more Fame I mean it's
because because kids now like when we go
out on college campuses and Weiner just
got a great Tick Tock or Instagram where
he's walking on USC and like no one even
recognizes him and it's because you kind
of forget like we've moved everyone's
moved on and they didn't see us play but
you then see like fans who are like hey
man we need to give Richie his Heisman
back like you see it everywhere you go I
mean it's literally followed him and you
forget the dudes won a Super Bowl like
he's he's had other accomplishments he's
got to date a Kardashians he might be a
bigger reality TV star a known for Kim
Kardashian that relationship
um and so it's crazy though because it's
actually continued to follow him I don't
know I think you got to keep milking it
hit a Wendy's commercial
I don't know maybe it's not such a bad
thing right now I think Pete Rose has
benefited from not being in the Baseball
Hall of Fame because he's still in the
news he's still relevant if not he'd be
just a you know a Hall of Fame gamer
sign an autograph somewhere no one
really care you know people Champion
Pete's cause hey now you can gamble on
baseball why can't Pete get back into
baseball yeah and I said no no it
doesn't work that way I just I want to
know where the heisman's at that's what
I want to know no we got it back oh you
got it back yeah so you did get it back
yeah all I was paying attention to is
the San Diego Sports Hall of Fame or
whatever that was I've I've had a Hall
of Champions
no Champions no Paulie had somebody who
reached out to him said I I have the
Heisman here he's they had it yeah huh
and here's all I know is Linus was in
his closet we asked him one time like
where it was he told us it was like
under some clothes in the back of his
closet somewhere well Carson Palmer had
his out in the garage yeah and I asked
him if he could send it to me and he did
so he we had his Heisman for six eight
months because he said nobody I don't
use I mean what do you do with it I mean
it I don't know I don't have one so I
wouldn't know my awards are at my mom's
house but you finished what fourth in
the Heisman third and fourth third and
fourth yeah yeah it's always fun to be
there uh but the bush push you can do
that now I couldn't do it back then yeah
yeah but if liner if that ball doesn't
go out of bounds
on third down right well the clock
should have kept running and they did
get a favorable spot yeah but that's at
Notre Dame so I I yeah but we always had
the uh the opposing teams back then we
had their officials right because we're
independent so we don't have our
officials so I believe it was a Pac-12
officiating crew give me the scenario
where Notre Dame would join a conference
oh that's a good question I would say
this scenario would I think it would be
twofold it'd be one in which it'd be too
hard to pass up what you would be
compensated by joining a conference
um probably through a broadcast TV
meteorites deal uh coupled with
coupled with the fact that everyone that
you're trying to schedule is pretty much
in that conference right so if you think
about the traditional opponents you're
always going to have your West Coast
trip either Stanford USC
um you know back when I was playing we
always had a Michigan Michigan State
Purdue we had those big ten schools if
all of a sudden you're looking at a
world where we're living in college
football where there's maybe only four
power four conferences autonomous
conferences or two in that and that's in
this case you might be saying to
yourself well what's holding them back
from just joining at that point
um especially if it's in order for them
to be able to stay competitive you know
you're making this big TV rights media
deal as well and you can't get that
staying independent I think it's those
two things where you really can't turn
to create a schedule that doesn't make
sense but I'm wondering if you know
these conferences say you're only
playing the schools in the conference
therefore you you take away Notre Dame's
schedule from them so then they're going
to be playing army and Air Force Navy
right uh maybe some ACC schools but they
could do that and I obviously you would
have to create a scenario where you have
so many conference games that you're
eliminating non-conference games right
yeah because what I always advertise to
people and people who want to challenge
Notre Dame to joining conference they
say we're your best non-conference game
yeah we are who you use to justify win
or lose why you should get into the
college football playoff so why do you
want us to join a conference like you're
welcome college football you're welcome
yes all right yeah yes well I think
Notre Dame
bold move here joins the Pac-12 okay all
right
that's uh Champions very which is now
the about the pack seven
I think it's four four yeah yeah who
would be the partner you didn't even
numbers so you have to have one more
uh SMU sure yeah yeah that makes sense I
mean
we're gonna place that had the death
sentence well well nothing makes sense
in college football anymore yeah it
feels a little chaotic right now I think
I think Rutgers leaves the Big Ten
and no one would know and joins the
Pac-12
then we add Tulsa
of course uh and then round it out with
uh Fresno State there you go that'll do
it you can I just you know what I'm
gonna make it I just fixed it I I just
told you no no you fix it you should be
the next one pack the new Pac-12
commissioner and you should take it I
would I would do a better job than uh
the current person well you're right
about that uh Brady do you have a
question for uh Will Ferrell
oh I wasn't prepared for this
um I guess my I asked you upstairs you
really didn't say yeah because I thought
like you know you came here with the
crew like you'd be rooting for another
day coming to Ireland or
no of course not no
no I'm I'm so like never there's no
chance you can just do hate Notre Dame I
wouldn't say hate No in fact I would say
the couple games I've been
the Notre Dame fans so nice amazing yeah
amazing yeah that's probably and part of
the problem though right they're too
nice no they were they were great and
you could talk football and it made the
Rival it was like oh this is a great
rivalry so I can't I wouldn't Hate's a
strong word but uh go midshipmen but the
but the fan base yeah with Ohio State
as opposed to Notre Dame growing up in
Ohio like herb Street ended up moving
out of Ohio yeah yeah like it's it's a
serious fan base whereas Notre Dame
strikes me as like the St Louis
Cardinals they were always a nice
friendly route for you it's a different
feel I mean clearly anytime a university
is attached to uh the Catholic Church
there's going to be that that sort of
portion of it but I think what's awesome
about college football which makes it so
special is it's it's more cultural like
I grew up in Columbus Ohio I I know
exactly what a lot of people right now
who are Ohio State fans are dealing with
losing to Michigan two years in a row
and then not even getting to plan during
the coveted years so it feels like it's
been so long since you got that win I I
grew up during the John Cooper era like
I remember what that was like they had
all these guys first round Talent going
to the NFL all these teams are on the
cusp and they couldn't beat Michigan and
or they you know they suffered something
in the bowl game and I remember how
miserable it was for Ohio State fans and
it's just it's that's a part of college
football they live and die by it
um and and so it's it's what makes the
story lines of the game fun um and so I
look
the passion's there it's awesome and and
I I never get upset when you you people
want to talk about like Ohio State fans
being like two of them I'm like no
that's how I should be they're
passionate about their team their fan
base Notre Dame fans are the same way uh
you might see more on message boards
because we're not all kind of you know
Century Located in one state but
um Notre Dame fans got the same passion
too I like to play the uh Brady Brady
Quinn bench press game
Todd uh start with you you have a bench
press
we don't have it here I come here and I
have to do a physical activity every
time I'm here well can we have a
Guinness I mean can we have some sort of
wow shot of Jameson but you and I are
hitting the gym later right are we yeah
I think so is that where we're doing
yeah why don't you two wrestle like you
want a physical activity will would you
wrestle Brady Quinn
oh okay there you go all right here we
go uh so
about the same height will looks like
he's wrestled before Greco Roman or what
record what's the what's the one oh you
want to get down down to fours and then
Brady you're not gonna hold on to him
I'm gonna I'm gonna let him stand up
okay okay
let's just stand up okay here we go
oh
wow I thought he grabbed oh God
Mercedes picked up well Brady just
he went below the belt by the way will
like I'm gonna take two points away from
him no you grabbed it you were you were
crotch bound I I was around the stomach
yeah I think it was legal
no it didn't I think I would know that
was all legal okay you're okay with that
you got a load of Beef O Brady right
there
yeah from our angle it looked like will
went too close to Brady's hair and then
it was go time yeah yeah there's there's
a few things I mean
and I can't blame him look at that I
mean that's that's like still hanging on
that's like Tom Cruise like you know
hairdo
it's a great head of hair I appreciate
it just take it just just run with it
yeah there are many compliments in this
room this week just like you say Fritz
is usually compliments me on my hair so
he's a very good looking guy there's a
little man crush there I was jealous of
will just now I didn't get that
wrestling opportunity
you know what I'm very comfortable with
my masculinity to say that's a very
handsome gentleman and if I had an
opportunity to wrestle with I probably
would not pass that it is a strange
sensation to be 57 years old
no I'm am I 56 well you're Hollywood you
lie about your age yeah right it's a
strange sensation to be a 42 year old
man
get picked up off the ground yeah
that was thrilling I do have a real
question for you you're blushing yeah
I'm a little yeah uh
yeah yeah yeah what do we got coming on
next as far as movies because obviously
that's right I'm enjoying my time in
Dublin
City rich in history yeah we're not
allowed to talk about that
get in trouble uh have you been out
picking have you seen the if Liffey
River will you're 56. I'm 56. thank you
okay uh we have take a break Brady
thanks for coming by thanks for having
me yeah
and you can you can hear Brady Monday
through Friday the show the precedes
owners to uh Frozen cup of joe with
LaVar Arrington yep and uh Jonas yes
Jonas Knox yes okay all right we'll take
a break we're back after this in The Dan
Patrick Show